[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everyone as some of you know
for the people who are supporting me on
patreon at at least a $10 level I'm
offering the possibility of suggesting
and then voting for subjects for the
future videos and so recently I put up a
question and I got many answers I think
I got like 30 suggestions but one of the
suggestions with god which got the top
votes which got the most votes was
suggested by John Moore and it is to
discuss the notion of the robe of light
in the Christian tradition there is this
idea that before the fall Adam and Eve
though in the Bible they're described as
being naked they were also clothed in
glory we could say that they were
surrounded by light and so someone had
asked me to talk about what exactly that
could refer to and so it I was actually
happy to see this I think I said the
suggestion was made by someone named
John Moore and so I'm pretty excited to
talk about that because it's something
that I have been pondering for quite a
while especially the relationship
between what you could call the robe of
light and the garments of skin and so
first of all what is this notion of the
robe of light why would we talk about
that now the idea that we are clothed we
have to compare we have to oppose the
two now when Adam and Eve fell in the
garden in the text it says that God
placed around them garments of skin now
the idea of garments of skin there are
several aspects to it and I hope to make
a video that talks just about the
garments of skin but a very important
part of what the garments of skin mean
is that there are covering they're a
protection from what is outside okay and
so around Adam because Adam had fallen
because there was something lacking in
Adam there needed to be a something
added to Adam in order to protect him
from the outside okay
and so now the garments of skin can be
seen
as many things and in the tradition it's
seen as our biological body or
biological existence the the very notion
that we need to add things to our nature
in order to survive we need to eat or
else we'll die the idea would be that in
the garden the the need to eat had more
to do with the kind of spiritual
communion with things rather than just
this notion of perpetuating this
biological body in the kind of living
death let's say but it also is whatever
need whatever is added and so all of
technology clothing being the first
technology all of technology is
something which we add in order to
protect ourselves as we move further and
further out into the world and so you
know you for example we could not live
in the north where I'm living here in
Quebec were not for the fact that we
have layers around us layers of clothing
and then layers of a house which protect
us from the cold without those layers of
added layers we would die in in in the
world so all of technology cities
whatever technology is seen as an
extension of this notion of the garments
of skin this added layer upon upon man
and this added layer is is dead that is
it is not it not it doesn't come from
our life but rather is taken from the
outside and added as these kind of
coarse dead layers which at the same
time protect us from death so it's a
it's a I keep using the image of a
vaccine it's a layer of death to protect
us from death okay now the notion that
Adam and Eve would be clothed in glory
clothed in light is the opposite of that
and so the notion that we would emanate
light let's say you know you hear that
even in yeah kind of new-age type
interpretation we have to understand it
yeah into what it means in terms of
being that is light shows things right
and so if you imagine Adam as generating
light then you imagine him as the source
and the light moving out from him
and casting light on things around him
so instead of him having to protect
himself from the outer world he becomes
an active revealer of the outer world
okay it's an extension of the idea that
Adam names the animals and so naming
something has to do with shedding light
on it casting a light on something and
and participating in its popping out
from the chaos okay in order for
something in the beginning and it says
let there be light and that's part of
this notion that the logos that light
there's a there's a chaotic potential
outside and then light comes and reveals
the forms that are there now you can
imagine you walk into a dark room and
you don't know where anything is you
don't know what's there you're kind of
wandering you're you're you're blind you
don't know what could kill you you don't
know anything but when you turn on the
light then you you you all of a sudden
everything is revealed and you can see
what is there now for example the
ancients talked about this idea that the
eye from the eye was this beam of light
like that that that there was a being
that came out of the eye and would hit
things too in order to reveal them to
the eye now we don't have to understand
that in a physical sense we need to
understand it more in the sense of this
relationship to naming that is the
capacity to focus on something the
capacity to pull out of the myriad of
details in the world to create unity and
to pull something out as having unity is
this participation in how the world lays
itself out okay it's an active
participation in how the world lays
itself out it's it that is that's what
we talk about when we talk about man
being in the image of God man naming the
animals the logos as what will pull out
order from chaos okay and so the notion
that Adam and Eve would be clothed in
light has to do with emphasizing that
aspect of the human being as
in its highest capacity to be able to
participate in creation to be part of
bringing out order out of chaos and also
participating in the life of God that is
that is what God does God creates the
world and so the human being by being
clothed in glory is also participating
in the life of God by naming the animals
by being the gardener by being by doing
all those things which which make man
which makes man in the image of God so
that can kind of help us understand what
the garment of light is and so if you
look now in the story of Christ you will
see certain moments in the story of
Christ where this lets say Christ is
represented as manifesting this garment
of light and so in the Transfiguration
there is the story where the disciples
are with Christ on the mountain they go
up on the mountain and then at the top
of the mountain
all of a sudden Christ appears in this
cloud of light and his garments are are
brilliant and white and and then next to
him is Moses and Elijah who all of a
sudden appear in this kind of
transfigured world and this notion of
the transfigured world is exactly this
idea of of light of light as being able
to manifest the the true essence of
things being able to see beyond let's
say just the the the fallen or kind of
material world in the sense of the world
which moves out into chaos moves out
into fragmentation but rather show the
world of manifestation it were not that
not that creation or the world of
manifestation is bad but rather there's
a way in which we can see it in which it
is full of light full of meaning okay
full of its full of its connection
together okay so maybe that can kind of
help us to understand the basic idea of
the the garments of light but there is a
really interesting
really interesting situation in the
story of Adam and Eve and the garments
of light and it's one which I think can
help us understand how human beings
understand things and how human beings
come to remember things because there's
a so we'll look at it and it might help
you to understand something else which
I'm hoping to get to more and more to
help people understand why religious
stories appear the way they do the
notion that Adam and Eve had garments of
light actually comes from the very same
text which says that Adam and Eve had
garments were given garments of skin and
so the word garments of skin the word
skin was interpret in the first century
before even Christianity kind of took
its uh its full shape was interpreted by
certain Jewish rabbis as being having an
alternate reading so the word skin could
also be read in some some transcriptions
in some ways of reading it as light so
it's very interesting that the tradition
about the garments of light are actually
the same as the garments of skin then
after that in the Christian tradition
this was developed more and more as as
talking to what was there before the
fall and then the garments of skin as
after the fall but the origin of the
tradition who came from the same text
which is this notion that Adam and Eve
were given garments of skin red all
alternatively as garments of light now
what does this mean what it as we as we
look then in the story of the of the of
the Bible you'll see this pattern where
the notion of the dead skins this notion
of death or this notion of the monstrous
or something similar
being alternative
being able to be read as light or glory
okay now there are many there are many
examples in in the text and it's very
similar to the tradition that we're
talking about another famous example is
in the story of Moses when Moses goes up
in order to encounter God when he comes
back down the text says that his face
shown his face was shining with glory
and he had to cover his face because his
face was shining okay now you can
imagine what that has to do Moses goes
back to the top of the mountain he goes
back to the same place in terms of
symbolism which is the center of the
garden which is the top of the the
garden where he is able to communicate
with God and so he becomes he once again
enters into the possibility of being a
radiating light that is of being the
source of meaning so when he comes back
down with the law which is the law of
God which which will order the Society
of the of the Israelites it's the same
thing as him shining with light those
two things are the same it's just
they're describing different different
aspects of it he is radiating light and
the law the law is let's say the the
logos manifesting itself in the world as
order which bringing order to chaos okay
now there is in in for example Saint
Jerome when he translated the text from
Greek into into Latin he mistranslated
the world the word which refers to glory
and instead he he translated it as horns
and so in the Latin version that the
reading of Moses coming down the
mountain was that when he came down the
mountain he was actually he had horns
and you can see that in certain
representations in the medio in medieval
art even up to Michelangelo you can see
that Moses is represented
with horns and you think wow that is
very strange that that that would happen
but what's interesting is that in Jewish
traditions a similar thing happened
where some rabbis began to say that in
fact the word which talks about glory
that Moses came down wearing with his
face shining could be interpreted as
being disfigured so that in in coming
back down the mountain
Moses would be disfigured and that's why
he had to cover his face now it's very
interesting that those two things happen
at the same time there is a that
tradition
it's almost everywhere even in the
Transfiguration itself in the
Transfiguration of Christ we see that it
says that Christ's vestment Shawn were
shut was shining with light but then it
talks that he was surrounded by a cloud
of light and the disciples were
overshadowed by this cloud of light
until in the very Transfiguration of
Christ you see this strange duality this
strange
aporia what seems like a contradiction
which is that on the one hand you have
light and on the other hand you have
this notion that the disciples are
overshadowed by a cloud a cloud of light
so it's this impossible bringing
together of darkness of confusion and
chaos because in the text it talks about
them also being confused but also light
this extreme light which which is
radiating out of Christ okay now what I
want to bring to you what I want to help
to try to talk to you about is to talk
about these patterns now what I what I
think and what I believe is that this
pattern this pattern of this
relationship between death and glory is
one which is very very deep and very
very profound and
and part of our human Constitution if I
even say that if I even tell you death
and glory you can all these examples in
your mind are going to come up of places
where we align those together where we'd
be celebrating people who died in battle
we have all these this imagery of the of
the soldier dying and receiving a crown
this notion of the martyr who dies and
receives a crown of glory there are many
examples of this relationship between
death and glory and in the very words
those relationship sips are there for
example in in in many languages the word
for crown and the word for horn that is
the horns of an animal they're the same
words you can even hear Horn crown in
French we say Cong for horn and Coogan
for crown and in many languages the two
are related and so this notion of this
animality these crown these horns like
Moses who came down the mountain with
these with this animal aspect to him
like the dead garments of animal skins
added to Adam is is related is from the
same source as the notion of a crown
let's say of a king's crown of this
crown of glory and it goes so far that
you can even find this relationship in
the in fairytales for example in the
story of Cinderella there is this notion
that Cinderella has glass slippers well
in the original the older versions her
in French we say that she had her shoes
were made of fur in French the word for
fur a certain type of fur was vibe and
so she had shoes made of VAT and then
the word for glass is also VAT and so
there's a slip that happened between
this notion that she had shoes made of
animal fur which which became shoe
who's made of glass and so the same
relationship between something which is
opaque and related to this added layer
of death and something which is clear
and which transmits light and so it it
just it's just a structure which happens
over and over now one of the things that
I think that happens yeah
and this is gonna throw a big monkey
wrench in the way that historical kind
of critical analyses happen is that what
I believe is that with the way we
remember things things that happened a
very long time ago
sometimes even in so people will say for
example that these are just mistakes and
transcriptions and so someone in the
Cinderella story wrote the word vibe a
little bit differently and so it was
interpreted by somebody else as being
glass in the in the tendus notion of
garments of skin garments of light it
was someone who had Mis transcribed or a
misreading of the text which brought
people to say garments of light instead
of garments of skin and you see kind of
the historical critical analysts always
making those types of criticism wanting
to rectify some mistake horrible
mistakes done by those stupid people in
the Middle Ages which we now owe now we
understand that according to this
reading but that is a very that's up to
me that's a bad way of going about
because what I think is that there are
always mistakes in transcriptions there
are always there are always moments
where there can be little confusions but
when such a mistake persist not only
persist but is also received and
accepted by the tradition by a group by
a community
it's as if okay so it says if you have a
pattern okay you have this pattern and
then the world as it manifests itself
and it's chaotic for and it's chaos will
sometimes go out of the pattern or
sometime manifest something slightly
different but then what happens is even
through mistakes or through miss
readings or through misunderstanding
it's as if things want to snap back into
the regular pattern
the all of reality is working to bring
things back into the regular pattern and
so the fact that we that we have we take
even a mistake in reading and persist
with it for so long and we bring it back
so that it manifests this pattern is
just how reality works and I know a lot
of people who might be annoyed at at
what I'm saying but what I'm suggesting
is that when we look at the past and
when we look at what what people have
transmitted to us it is important not
just to look at it in technical terms
and look at oh those morons
you know 2,000 years ago they just they
missed understood this aspect they they
were missing a sentence in the text they
miss transcribed this part all this
baloney because I mean now that it's
baloney maybe it did happen it doesn't
matter we also need to look at how
something is remembered because the way
that it's remembered and the way that it
persists through time actually can show
us more about human nature and about
reality ultimate reality let's say then
simply nitpicking at the details and how
the details were gotten right or wrong
and that's really important I've talked
about this even in terms of let's say
the history of the Trojan War let's say
when you hear scholars who will nitpick
at the text given to us by Homer and
we'll try to find some archaeological
proof that you know maybe some little
part of the text is actually true and is
actually historically real and then
they'll discount everything else as if
you know none of that has any value
because we can't prove it
archaeologically well you're missing the
whole point of how the story of the
Trojan War and the reason why it has
persisted for so long is because it
shows us something far more profound
than simply an accurate representation
of some event which happened you know
six you know fifteen hundred years ago
yeah in in an inn in Anatolia it's like
that's not what that's not what it
that's not what's important what's not
that I'm saying the Trojan War never
happened I think it happens doesn't
bother me too
that the Trojan War happened but the way
it's described and the way that the
pattern came to now synchronize itself
let's say with the deeper patterns of
being that's important to notice as well
because it tells us way more about
ourselves and so then what is this deal
about this deal about the garments of
light and the garments of skin and what
I would I believe is that it the
difference between the garments of light
between death and glory is really
depends on how you see it from what
perspective you're seeing it now in the
story of Christ what we see if we see
Christ joining those two together just
like Christ joins everything together
Christ takes the this manifestation of
the garments of skin death then he takes
this notion of the garments of glory and
then he brings them together into one
person and into one story whereas Christ
is on the cross this this whole idea
that he is both dying on the cross but
he is also extended and his body extends
to the limit of the world filling up the
world that is both at the same time this
reaching out to the edge of death this
entering into death but then changing
death into glory the same with the the
ultimate example that I keep keep
bringing back coming back to is the the
the crown of thorns the crown of thorns
is exactly those horns those pointy
defenses that were the consequence of
the fall in the Bible when Adam and Eve
fall God gives them garment give them
garments of skin but he tells them that
the world is going to produce thorns
these thorns as this defense against the
outside but this horn now this pointy
bit this thorn is
transformed by Christ by remate although
remaining what it is transformed into
this crown which he places on his head
which manifests also his glory and so
this this this capacity for taking that
which is added the the best way to see
it really is to see this notion of a
periphery as a circle right as this
added aspect as a circle and and the
circle has a lower part which would be
death right and so everything that is
dead everything that is added which is
exterior but there is a way to transform
that and bring it up to the highest part
which is the crown it's not that obvious
to know how that is but you can see
mysteries of that in in the Christian
Church a lot of people have asked me to
explain relics for example and because
relics are very strange to the modern
understanding there are basically bits
of dead people that become the actual in
the church they actually become focused
the focus of the glory of the the story
of the church and so how is that
possible well it really has to do with
this notion that death can be changed
into glory that this idea of these
peripheries that are added and added and
added can become they are in a way in
the deepest sense they they are the same
mystery as light which comes out and
manifests the world and so this added
thing this thing that comes out you can
see it either as it's as if the things
that come to protect you can be
transformed in things that make you
strong I don't think that that's in
terms of psychology I don't think that
that's that's that hard to understand
you have these you have these barriers
that you that you place these
protections that you that you have but
that once you kind of understand that
you have these these protections to
protect you from the outer world you can
actually flip them and transform the
in two ways in which you can then on the
on the contrary instead of just
protecting yourself from the other world
you your courage let's say can be
something that protects you but then can
act as something which then further is
you out into the world which makes you
engage further and further into chaos
bring more and more light into chaos
those two things are linked together and
in the story of the whole story of the
Bible you see it the the most in this
whole idea of how technology in the
story of Genesis is part of the fall and
so I've talked about this in other talks
before but this notion that the Genesis
is actually not just one fall but is
actually a series of Falls and so God
gives to Adam and Eve the garments of
skin and then after that you have
another fall with Cain and Abel and then
Cain creates a city so you have the
garments of skin then Cain creates this
city and then he creates technologies
different technologies including weapons
of war which bring about all these
conflicts and then that brings us all
the way to chaos all the way to the
flood which is this return to chaos now
so you can see it as a fall fall fall
fall fall fall fall until the world is
completely destroyed but now at the end
of the Bible this whole whole big story
at the very end of the Bible you see in
Revelation this image of the heavenly
Jerusalem and so this notion of the city
but this glorious City the shining city
in which all the elements of the city
are are you know symbolically
represented as gold and precious stones
and all and it's all to represent this
notion of the tough technology of what
was the originally this garments of skin
now transformed into this glorious
manifestation basically the crown of
creation and so the the New Jerusalem is
is basically this crown because it
talked about the New Jerusalem coming
down from heaven and so this crown which
comes down on creation and then
manifests the possibility of
all of this coming together of death
technology and all these things being
transformed into something higher which
is which is full of light and so I can't
actually tell you how that can totally
happen but sometimes we have these small
glimpses of how that could happen I
talked about this this notion of of
let's say of courage or how our own
passions let's say we have these these
desires let's say we have a desire to
eat and this desire to eat can lead us
out into into a kind of loss of control
where we have this these this constant
desire to eat certain things and we
think that you know and it we feel like
we're a slave to our belly you know
everybody has had that that that let's
say that experience but it could also be
the sexual desire it can also be the
certain thought patterns like whatever
but then that lets say that desire to
eat food can then be transformed into
something higher for example in in in
the Christian liturgy
that's why communion part of communities
that we're eating and so this desire to
eat which can actually bring you further
and further is transformed into
something which actually brings
everybody together and then manifest
something which is higher and so the
very and so the that's just a small
example of how something which leads you
out into chaos can then be flipped
around and transformed into something
which actually brings everything
together and manifests unity and light
and all those things and so that's a
little bit of a glimpse of of what the
garments of glory can mean and I hope
that it was helpful I know that when I
talk about more religious things
sometimes it can get a bit sometimes a
bit more abstract so I hope that I'm
being clear enough if not please go
ahead and ask the questions in the
question in the comment section and I'll
try to engage I try to engage as as much
as I can as I've told you before
Mateusz book it's coming out like now
it's just like I swear to all of you
it's really weeks away I mean hopeful
maybe even days away so we're hoping to
see matches book come out until there
there's a lot of things coming soon also
I'm my next movie review will probably
be about black panther and so you'll
hear news about that coming soon and so
alright guys it was good to talk to you
you know share this all all the things
you know subscribe if you're not
subscribed and please consider
supporting us on patreon you know even
just one dollar makes a huge difference
as I'm trying to work towards making
this more inclusive having a website
putting up a podcast possibly also
putting up transcripts on on online but
all of that takes time and I do have
three kids and a family and so I trying
to balance out you know doing this and
and all my other things so it's use when
you support me on patreon it helps me to
get everything done and so yeah we'll
see you soon